do you have a tattoo that you're
embarrassed of um
god there's a terrible tattoo story i
have a really bad
uh and i'll just tell it okay
um the uh
long long time ago i i arrived at the
conclusion that i do not want to have
kids
no interest whatsoever this is going to
lead into a tattoo story
you bet why don't you want to have kids
ah
and i'm glad that you came on a podcast
with a guy and his daughter to explain
now you're going to see who also has
kids
yeah right it's okay no thank you
and and i will i will get to the point
here uh one night i was
i was drinking heavily with some friends
and and uh
it's better than alone right and i
thought ah you know
like i'll get a tattoo maybe of uh
of a a baby with uh
the circle and the slash you know like
no no babies no babies
like the opposite of baby on board no
babies i get it well that makes sense
right because you made the decision but
we kept drinking
kept drinking and then i said uh that
would be a great logo for a condom
company
right right but then the idea quickly
changed the more we drink and uh just a
tattoo that says [ __ ] babies
right but i think but i figured that i
was already kind of word heavy
you know at the time i had uh you hit
and [ __ ] tattooed on my knuckles i've
since gotten that lasered off
that works the laser the removable yeah
it's pretty good yeah but uh the sad
truth is that by the time
uh i made it to the tattoo parlor that
night
i ended up getting a tattoo of a guy
[ __ ] a baby
no i said yeah i it was
it was and and in my defense no there
isn't any
so so
where is this tattoo it's on my dick
it's on his penis
he puts a baby just on the end of his
penis
the head of your penis is a baby face
going
so it looks like it's going right into
the back there is no defense ah
hey that was awful man that that was it
i it was right here
and then uh what happened was um
i uh showed it to my buddy bam
i was like dude this is awful man i
gotta like oh actually
i i went i know when you're in trouble
and you think there's something off and
you really want to straighten out your
life who do you go to
bam right i
um i knew it was a mistake by the time i
left the tattoo parlor
because it just it just clicked like
that after after
how many hours does it take to uh to
create a baby uh
[ __ ] a baby how long does that take
it was a pretty quick uh
quick meaning what just give me an idea
i don't have a tattoo i'm gonna say
about an
hour or maybe not even less than an hour
maybe an hour so within 55
minutes within almost an hour you were
sure that [ __ ] a baby
is is not right the the moment
that the moment when it really became
clear was when i
came out of the tattoo parlor i'm
standing on the sidewalk right outside
the joint
yeah and there was a couple walking down
the street with a baby
no but they were very excited to
recognize me oh steve i was
gonna you know you could see them right
they lit up they came to meet me
and i sort of proudly showed them my arm
where i had this
fresh new tattoos to check out my new
tattoo and
the look of absolute horror on their
face spoke volumes and i knew
okay i've crossed the line here this is
not fun or funny
and uh how long did you have to hold on
to that before you changed it
i i lasted less than a month
and that's that's like so only like 27
days of [ __ ] a baby
well well right that's what i want to
call this episode of the podcast
27 days of [ __ ] the baby with stevo
why not
i did i cross the line
let him cross the line himself dad right
so
i mean i i i this this was back in 2006.
oh
so that's when things were different
that's way before the me too movement or
any of this
absolutely that's when it was okay to
[ __ ] a baby i get it
i don't even know that that was okay
then but uh it was back in 2006 and we
were filming
yeah there it is oh
my god oh my god yeah oh my gosh
that was pretty bad and you really look
in this picture that we're
looking at and you'll see it if you it's
not a flattering picture no but it's not
only that
that is not the face of regret at the
time
i yeah at that time i'm sure i was
really on drugs and and drunk who knows
what that's you looking at the
lovely young couple who just uh who just
look what i got
who knows what state of mind i was in
when that photo was taken
um but it was while we were filming
jackass number two
our second theatrical jackass release
and uh
we were filming in india right after i
got this tattoo and all the scenes
that were shot in india i had a bandana
tied around my arms so
even because you didn't want to offend
the people of india i just
i just didn't even want it you know so
if you see in jackass number two like
i've got a bandana tied around my arm
while i'm in india to cover it up
and that was what kind of held up the
process of me
addressing it as soon as we got back i
went into a tattoo parlor and just
went over it myself i turned the baby
into a black blob
and it was my buddy bam who saw that and
he said dude
you should turn that blob into an
ostrich
oh wow wow so i
turned so i turned the baby into an
ostrich and it was it went from like
[ __ ] a baby to
[ __ ] ostrich which which is
acceptable right so now i've got the the
the guy in the ostrich riding a
motorcycle
when did you stop [ __ ] it when it
rode away on the bike yeah they're
riding the motorcycle
uh but isn't that dangerous i'm noticing
that the ostrich on the motorcycle
doesn't have a helmet
it's it's a quality problem
you